okay we're on CNN now I don't know how
that happened but we're back with our
panel from Vermont Bernie Sanders the
senator
host of showtimes for circus John
heilman and actor ingredient Russell
Brand are back with us
okay so here are the questions
people wrote in I guess this is for you
because it mentions the Brit Awards what
does the panel think of the discussion
around the Oscars getting rid of
gender-specific categories like best
actor and best actress and how did it
work out at the Brit Awards
an award I feel confident in saying that
they are vacuous and pointless a
distraction at a time where we need to
be coming together around real
principles and values unless someone
wants to give me an award in which case
I'd like to make it as specific as
possible so I could bloody well get it
am I wrong that at the the Brit Awards
which is for music I hosted that before
but I'll tell you bill that I was able
to let go of the experience and have
never thought about it since
[Laughter]
used to be best male best female and
they just cut out the categories and it
was one like it was only the only people
who won it was it was four men and Harry
Styles
yeah
yeah I think no all that like no women
won they should just give Awards to
Harry Styles and that can be an industry
okay
the world incinerates
well Harry Styles dances beautifully
what is
what is the likelihood that Congress
will abolish daylight savings time this
is something I've read this also today
that uh so like they're calling it the
permanent daylight savings I don't
really understand even understand what
that could mean do you care about this
are you
[Applause]
I I have to I have been criticized for
having a very narrow Focus
criticism a daylight savings time is not
one of the issues that I've been
studying okay
you know what I bet you it's the kind of
stuff that actually affects a lot of
adults and and it's and it's
anachronistic it's stupid I don't get it
I don't know I guess we did it a hundred
years ago because Farmers needed okay
well how many people in America are
farmers it's like one percent of the
population I mean we need the farmers I
love food
foreign
I'm not crazy about the way they do
their farming torturing animals and by
the way to just to connect it once more
to covid we are never going to be done
with diseases like covet while we are
still torturing animals it all comes
from animals it comes now we have to
worry about bird flu
bird flu it's Birds and pigs we're back
in the wet Market again where it's like
that's that's yeah it's like there's
there's bad that goes on in those
places that's right and that's why that
also could be where it came from but it
always jumps from animals to people and
it wouldn't if we didn't pan up the
animals and torture them before we eat
them it seems like and let me be let me
be not in funny you know your point
about sickness and the possibility of
future pandemics
absolutely speaks to the need for
international cooperation
because the pandemic is not going to be
an American issue it's not going to be a
Chinese issue we're gonna have to bring
the world together to deal with climate
to deal with pandemics okay uh should
law enforcement be policing Tech talk in
order to crack down on illegal trends
like the viral challenge to steal kids
and Hyundai
oh yeah do you know about this they
there's Tick Tock videos that show how
you could with just a I think a
screwdriver and a iPhone charger you can
hot wire a Kia and Hyundai so like
they're being stolen left and right
um what do you think about tech talk
that's another thing that's before
Congress somebody has a bill to ban Tick
Tock certainly for people under 16. I
think that's Josh Hawley well I think
the concern is Tick Tock is a Chinese
owned company and you're seeing States
and the US government
uh not wanting to use it for fear that
some secretive information could fall
into Chinese hands well but also it's
rotting the minds of our young well it's
a whole other story but that's that's
Beyonce's talk isn't it it is but Tick
Tock is not helping I would say the rod
the rotting of the minds of the America
of America's youth is a is a problem
that existed long before Tick Tock and
it made it like one of the things great
things about being young made it much
worse kids at least used to read a book
I don't think kids ever see a book they
do not read they scroll a scrolling does
not make you smart uh you know not to
become overly serious I think it is now
perceived that pen that the pandemic has
made the Mental Health crisis that we
previously had even worse and there is a
lot of discussion about the impact of
social media and the isolation is
absolutely human contact that it
develops absolutely on our health all
right Russell what are your thoughts on
the UFOs that were intercepted and shot
down by the U.S military last month I
don't know if they're referring to the
Chinese balloons they were not UFOs
because we know what they were they were
Chinese balloons
uh but there were other things there
were some things that they shot that we
didn't get and we don't know what they
are and they're the things that we
haven't found out what they are after we
did shoot them down I wonder whether or
not the 14 trillion dollars that that
have been granted to the Pentagon 55 of
which has ended up in the hands of the
military industrial complex which surely
American people are becoming weary of
needs occasionally to be boosted with
fanciful ideas of extraterrestrial
Invasion maybe there needs to be a
continual reminder that the skies
themselves could become a threat unless
Raytheon Lockheed Martin BAE Systems
continue to profit elsewise a balloon a
perfect metaphor for it is naught but
hot air nothing inside it shot down by a
four hundred thousand dollar missile
might be coming for your family
[Applause]
I mean
we we we're just saying here we all
should be skeptical and have open minds
on everything it is possible that there
are there's life in on other planets
that are visiting us or scouting us I
mean there are even even the U.S
well Carl
Insurance Cloud possible but if you
think that something from Another
Universe came all the way here and was
just kind of dragging around and was
shot down very easily
I think if it's a UFO they would have
done a little bit better in avoiding and
waiting
first of all
it's we're not saying it's from Another
Universe we're saying it's from the same
universe universe is very big very big
Bill I think bunny raises a good point
it's not like E.T would come all the way
here and then trip up outside Elliot's
house
[Applause]
no that's the boy
the Chinese balloon is different I'm not
saying the Chinese balloon was from
Another Universe or this one I mean it
doesn't have to be from China if it's a
Chinese balloon and I mean that of all
due respect unless that's the least it
can do well
I'm
moving on the obvious
if you brought Bernie back out here he
won't be happy if you're going to talk
about extraterrestrials and balloons
okay if you're looking for inequality if
you're looking for proof that there's
life in outer space intelligent life and
Aerospace you need to look no further
than Russell there's not really another
accounting for how I I'm glad that
became a compliment sir because I was
rearing up no don't you worry oh holy
copper that's my friend with all the
emphasis on Dei are we confusing
equality of opportunity with trying to
guarantee equity and outcomes okay
that's interesting because I think this
word Equity is coming to the language in
the last few years and before that we
didn't hear it a lot and I think a lot
of people hear equity and they hear
equality I think it's the same word and
it's not the same word in the same
concept so how would you differentiate
between equity and equality
well the quality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
coming to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it not
I mean I think so I think okay so which
do you come which side do you come down
on
equality equality yeah okay
boys any comment on that one I just
don't know if that's the that's the
definitional difference but certainly
this is the question of the quality of
outcome over over our quality of
opportunity is one that you know has
been it's the question that underlies
affirmative action and everything else
that we've had in our projects for a
very long time and there's obviously
people are very strong even people who
actually want a quality of outcome say
they only want a quality of opportunity
and vice versa but that's you know
that's the it's a that that issue that
core of that what do you actually want
um and I think Bernie is where everyone
says they want to be but there are in
fact programs that have been designed
that designed to actually engineer equal
outcomes not just equal opportunity and
that's where a lot of the controversies
risen okay one more have Democrats done
enough to support strong labor unions
Bernie what's the future of unions in
this country I think they just
subpoenaed the Starbucks they didn't I
did uh you know so
that's not fair
they're not going to have that is an
issue I do know something about and
what I pay attention to and the bottom
line is that you're not going to have a
middle class in this country unless
workers are able to stand up organize
form unionism and negotiate for decent
contracts and what we're seeing right
now is more and more workers wanting to
form unions but you're seeing companies
like Starbucks and Amazon and other
apple and other large corporations
really engaging in illegal union busting
so we have asked uh the leader of
Starbucks they had a CEO Howard Schultz
to explain to us why he thinks it's
acceptable that over 50 occasions the
nlrd has said they have broken federal
labor law in Breaking unions so we hope
to have him come before our committee
there will be a vote on Wednesday at a
vote on subpoena subpoenaing it does
seem like there is a
a strange sort of
hypocrisy there because these are
usually liberal companies I think Whole
Foods also and it's like they care a lot
about the indigenous people of the
Bolivian Andes but not about some work
or incense you got it all right uh very
liberal about everything except where
the workers can form a union and earn
decent wages they're very Pueblo
except whether or not we ask them to pay
their fair share of taxes they're not so
liberal then that's right thank you
everybody
foreign